est de trouver des moyens pour promouvoir et activer
ces cellules souches déjà présentes dans le cerveau
pour qu'elles réagissent et répondent de manière appropriée aux lésions
pour les réparer.
C'est notre futur.
Nous aurons des médicaments qui feront cela.
Mais l'autre méthode consiste à parachuter des cellules,
de les transplanter,
pour remplacer des cellules mourantes ou perdues, même dans le cerveau.
Je veux vous faire part d'une expérience,
il s'agit d'un essai clinique que nous avons fait,
que nous avons récemment terminé,
avec des collègues de UCL [University College London],
David Miller en particulier.
Cette étude était très simple.
Nous avons pris des patients atteints de sclérose en plaque
et nous avons posé une question simple :
est-ce que des cellules souches de la moelle osseuse
protégeraient leurs nerfs ?
Ce que nous avons fait, c'est que nous avons pris cette moelle osseuse,
fait croître les cellules souches en laboratoire,
et réinjecté ces cellules dans la veine.
Ça a l'air très simple quand j'en parle.
Ça a pris cinq ans à beaucoup de monde, d'accord ?
Et ça m'a donné des cheveux gris
et ça a posé plein de problèmes.
Mais conceptuellement, c'est très simple.
Donc nous les avons injectées dans la veine, n'est-ce pas ?
Donc pour savoir si nous avions réussi ou non,
nous avons pris le nerf optique
comme indicateur de résultat.
Et c'est pratique à mesurer dans le cas de la sclérose en plaques,
car les patients atteints de sclérose en plaques
souffrent malheureusement de problèmes de vision --
perte vision, vision non claire.
Nous avons donc mesuré la taille du nerf optique
en utilisant les scanners avec David Miller
trois fois -- douze mois, six mois,
et avant l'injection de cellules --
et vous pouvez voir la ligne rouge décliner doucement.
Ça vous indique que le nerf optique se contracte,
ce qui est logique, puisque les nerfs sont en train de mourir.
Puis nous avons injecté les cellules aux patients
et répété la mesure deux fois --
trois mois et six mois --
et à notre surprise, ou presque,
la ligne est remontée.
Cela suggère que l'intervention
a protégé le nerf.
Je ne crois pas que ce qui est arrivé
est que les cellules souches ont produit de la nouvelle myéline
ou de nouveaux nerfs.
Je crois que ce qu'elles ont fait, c'est de promouvoir
les cellules souches endogènes ou cellules précurseurs,
pour qu'elles fassent leur travail, qu'elles déposent de la nouvelle myéline.
C'est la preuve du concept.
Je suis très heureux de ça.
Je voudrais terminer avec le thème que j'ai abordé au départ,
la régénération et l'espoir.
Là, j'ai demandé à John
quels sont ses espoirs pour le futur.
John : J'espère qu'un jour
dans le futur,
grâce à la recherche que vous menez,
nous pourrons trouver un remède,
de sorte que les gens comme moi pourrons mener une vie normale.
SC : Cela en dit beaucoup.
Mais je voudrais conclure d'abord en remerciant John --
le remercier pour m'avoir autorisé à partager son point de vue
et ces vidéos avec vous tous.
Mais je voudrais aussi ajouter, à l'intention de John et des autres,
qu'à mon avis, il y a de l'espoir pour le futur.
Je crois réellement que les technologies disruptives
telles que les cellules souches que j'ai tenté de vous expliquer
offrent une réelle source d'espoir.
Je crois réellement que le jour où nous serons capables
de réparer un cerveau endommagé
arrivera plus rapidement que nous ne le pensons.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)